remercie c'est à partir d'aujourd'hui
quand on entre en application
et ici on du gouvernement en matière de
sécurité sociale à commencer par les
augmentations de cotisations de 1%
c'est monsieur jean fargeot secrétaire
d'état le nouveau secrétaire d'état à la
sécurité sociale ne met tout
spécialement à cet effet auprès du
ministre de la santé monsieur barreau
qui nous rappelle les principes
essentiels de cette réforme
dans une interview qu'il a accordée à
chaque merlyn il faut comprendre que le
rythme de croissance des dépenses de
santé ne peut être abandonné à lui-même
qu'il faut tenir compte des nécessités
c'est que l'a8 dans lesquelles nous
trouvons et que nous ne pouvons pas en
ce domaine comme dans beaucoup d'autres
dépenser plus que nous gagnons et par
conséquent le principe c'est d'arriver à
une modération des dépenses de santé qui
soit à la mesure du rythme de croissance
de notre économie nationale
dans ce but première mesure les tarifs
des consultations des médecins des
dentistes seront bloqués jusqu'en 1981
s'agissant de médecins mais les médecins
ne seront pas seuls concernés
nous avons décidé de ne pas approuver
l'avenant tarifaire qui a été conclu
entre ces médecins la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie
pour ce qui concerne les augmentations
qui était prévu au mois d'octobre 1979
et au mois de janvier 1980 en vérité au
fond des choses
ce que nous souhaitons c'est que la
convention lie les médecins la caisse
nationale d'assurance maladie puissent
être rediscuté de manière à tenir compte
des normes et qui nous le croyons
s'impose au fonctionnement du système la
sécurité sociale c'est d'ailleurs des
normes de progression des dépenses de
soins de santé
ces normes sont simples la progression
des dépenses santé ne va pas être
supérieure à la croissance économique
mais les médecins les dentistes ne
seront pas les seuls concernés les
pharmaciens aussi seront mis à
contribution
la contribution leur sera demandé
prendra très vraisemblablement la forme
d'une ristourne sur leur chiffre
d'affaires
ça veut dire qu'une certaine fraction de
leur recette sera reversée à la sécurité
sociale
c'est une mesure là aussi de
contribution exceptionnelle ce ne sera
pas une mesure d'ordre permanents et les
modalités d'application pratique de
cette mesure sont actuellement en
discussion avec les organisations
représentatives de la profession des
pharmaciens elles devront se traduire
par une baisse d'1 à un demi pour cent
du revenu des pharmaciens et puis
mesures très importantes les budgets des
hôpitaux seront bloqués jusqu'à la fin
d'année la vérité les les budgets des
hôpitaux publics ne sont pas bloquées
nous avons simplement indiqué que cette
année la différence des précédentes les
dépenses pour l'année 1979 des hôpitaux
publics devaient rester dans les limites
de leur budget de 1979 qu'il n'y aurait
pas de budget supplémentaire en 1979
pour les hôpitaux publics
bien entendu
cette mesure est une mesure globale et
nous savons très bien qu'il y a
plusieurs hôpitaux en france et que leur
cap fait éventuellement différents et
c'est pourquoi l'application de cette
mesure sera et concentré c'est à dire
que nous demandons au préfet en liaison
avec les directeurs et responsables
d'hôpitaux de bien vouloir appliquer
cette mesure de blocage cette
déconcentration dans l'application des
mesures nous donne la garantie que dans
tel ou tel cas particulier nous
pourrions apporter les assouplissements
qui s'avérerait indispensable mais le
principe général est bien celui que je
vous indique pour l'année 1979
pas de budget supplémentaire nous
restons dans les limites des budgets que
l'on appelle primitif de l'année 1979
enfin dernière mesure une contribution
exceptionnelle les assurés avec une
cotisation supplémentaire de 1% sur
l'ensemble du salaire je puis affirmer
ici que ceux de prélèvement de 1 % pour
dix pendant 18 mois à compter du 1er
août 1970 mois d'août 1979 est un
prélèvement exceptionnel c'est à dire
limiter dans le temps limité à ces 18
mois